this is nick from wisconsin nick with
the
mr blue eyes what's up guys this is nick
from wisconsin
uh i got a debate club for you
who's the better faker rachel dolezell
or hilaria
baldwin game game buzz buzz dude
and that hilario baldwin's getting tore
the [ __ ] up
now we're speaking of snitches now her
classmates are sending old pictures of
her when she said she was in spain
shows her in [ __ ] boston in high
school
some school play she's getting outed i
don't get why she was trying to pretend
she was from [ __ ]
spain what's the point just be from
[ __ ] boston
who gives a [ __ ] have you seen this theo
i don't know about this
you don't you don't know about this bra
she's getting lit up right now she's
alec baldwin's wife
and she she would go on like the today
show she was a correspondent for extra
but she would go on the today show
and she would give like this weird
spanish accent
and she was like in your culture you say
cucumber
you say cucumber and then you realize
she's just a white girl from boston
she was literally like she's this year's
rachel dolezal she's been acting like
she's been spanish speaking for
and she's from western massachusetts or
something yeah i'd say
that rachel uh does acts way worse she's
the head of the n
n a double c p or double n a double a
whatever the [ __ ] it is n a c bro
she was basically the ovary she was the
ovary mlk bro for real
i thought dolazal was dope she was
trying to do good stuff for black people
she was just trying to be involved
she was basically just woe vicki but 15
years old
yeah she was yeah she was older woe
vicki and just dyed her skin
all black though but she was doing good
[ __ ] she was really helping them out and
then they [ __ ] kick her out of the
club
yeah it's like kind of like that's the
thing sometimes you just gotta look if
people are helping you keep them
involved man
you know it's like i don't know at least
rachel was doing some
the lord's work and trying to help black
people out this lady's just stealing the
[ __ ]
culture of spanish people for no reason
but check that check this out theo
here's uh oh this is the clip
i mean so what happens with it it's not
like what's she gonna can she still
podcast
probably patreon only yeah at this point
and she's a real person
yeah real white person oh the hillary uh
baldwin cucumber pretends to be spanish
that's the video you're looking for
you see it oh yes that's it that's the
one i saw
she really went over the top
did she yeah i listen
to cancel her from she's just a mom we
have tomatoes
we have um cucumber
cucumbers we have um red pepper
we have of course
and there's there's millions of examples
she said like she's been asked point
blank and she's like oh my family is
from spain but they were like
vacationing there and she made it sound
like they were there until she was 18.
i it just senseless really i don't know
what she's getting out of it yeah i just
don't get why she does it
like what's that what's the point what's
the narrative no one's like oh she's
from spain let's give her a [ __ ] job
with e i don't get it but who care
here's the thing
especially now we got ancestry six what
is it ancestry sixty ancestry.com
you got uh you got 13 ways to die
listen theo pretended he's a straight
male we don't cancel him
oh come on man dude i've definitely
spent more time with women than you have
bro let's be honest
uh next week's uh king instinct guest
host uh tim dillon tweeted hilaria
baldwin was just picked up by ice
[Laughter]
[Music]